hey what's up Danny two are here with
julio pac pac man hating my friend
warcraft and the trailer came out today
the public trailer and I'm a big world
of warcraft old-school head I don't know
half as much about the lore as you do ah
kind of I know a lot of people are gonna
correct this my lord knowledge is not
that great but probably been in office
yeah so we're gonna go through the
latest trailer for warcraft and try and
pick out and all the sort of I guess
lower elements in there and you know I
guess for people who don't really know
much about Warcraft first of all what
time frame are we looking at here just
like pre-work we're looking at the
beginning of Warcraft one before like
everything starts to hit the fan right
so this is before the orcs go through
the door dark portal so humans and orcs
at this stage never met each other now
who the hell you know exactly so we'll
get to this Westfall situation in a
second let's start right at the start of
the trailer and very important to
Universal Pictures yeah legend cheers
great blizzard good call all right here
we go where's that this is all track
mountain mountains it could be anywhere
it could be yeah there could be done
Mora completely done more yeah we're the
weather um this is where everyone does
their battle grounds exactly yeah if it
is a delta which pic couple of people
are saying this situation here though
this does not I'm this is killing me I'm
trying to figure out a visit you have an
idea that you think it might be the
bottom like underneath the floating city
yes and no because that would be in
northrend okay but anyways this reminds
us of dollar an right yeah which it
won't be because we see that later on in
the clip but look it looks Meiji enough
looks Meiji this guy looks like he's
probably a mage that guy looks like meet
Eve yeah oh yeah perhaps right here we
leave residence the Dark Portal who's on
the back of Griffin probably Lothar the
main character yes get to it a little
bit which will be our protagonists what
we're looking at here this is good old
stormwind yes they had a big M this
seems like the biggest set like it looks
like they have built a part of it looks
cg here but I you're leading into
because they did build part of it right
yes apparently yeah
built a big set so I imagine a lot of
this movie because it's about humans is
gonna take place in and around stormwind
yeah it's looking pretty yeah it's great
this is definite on Iran right yeah cuz
that guy can definitely fall off of
those stairs I got the ghost his way
back to them of course because there's
Warcraft there's Lothar so who is Lothar
ah I only know so much about it I
remember controlling him and warcraft
one yeah but yes he's gonna be our main
character do you know more about
Lothar's I I do not the the politics of
early warcraft are a blur to me because
the thing is when you play World of
Warcraft you're basically coming in at
this stuff like decades down the road
yeah from a lot of it ah so the current
Prince of Stormwind is named after
Lothar right did you know that go for it
and doing Anduin Lothar yeah oh well
there's lots of luck we'll get some more
of those links with the orcs in a second
actually ah this is a whole fight what's
going on here I don't know what area
this is I think you had an idea of what
area this is right yes it looks like the
dam which is then subsequently broken
and Cataclysm on the right here this
whole section then then in the bottom
right yes and somewhere in the Eastern
Kingdoms from yes so not buy the whole
movie which is not super far from
Stormwind so it's the same kind of area
like to the east of the Elwynn forest
and that's kind of what that looks like
there's a skull getting broken there's
he's grieving or he's picking up armor I
can't tell maybe super happy about his
armor so I think that area that we were
looking at actually with the the dam or
the bridge yeah is that uh red Ridge
Mountains well does actually back here
there's yeah perhaps because I I
remember questing around that area you
cross a bridge right and then you go
into the little uh was it a the town the
little in right to pick up your daily
quests okay oh okay never dude you'd
like a lion's I my lord okay we it's
nice Elwynn forest yes you know it is
yeah it's just a stash yeah that's right
i forgot i forget the name of the bars
that's what it looks like today and this
is probably in the Elven forest as well
like the Dark Portal is close enough to
that part like it this looks like when
the orcs
first meets the humans right this looks
like what the hell is going on here
definitely I don't know how do we fight
these people oh gosh it is is that the
child's getting axed unless that's like
an editing trick so there's with RL
pissed there are king lane king lane
what's up I loved you in Mamma Mia guys
in everything and so he's kind of
freaked out because they're like who the
hell are all these orc beasts coming in
on our land so here we have perhaps
genre that's all I'm Danny dren are yeah
I guess and the green in the sky makes
me think that it has something to do
with the Burning Legion because they're
usually what full of felt magic Phil
magic is green so this is perhaps like
them going oh no we got to get out of
here and then I guess whatever happens
they get pushes the Dark Portal yeah
this looks like that's also trying to
adjust from nothing else about it is
that's just a barren sand as its
remember that area right where they they
call it what hellfire peninsula yes in
burning crusade I think that's oh really
that would be there because that's where
the Dark Portal is located right oh yeah
so then we see the other side of it so
this explosions interesting because here
is a bunch of trees and then a portal
blowing them all open or something
blowing them alone something's blowing
it up and that's probably the portal
being formed which will I refer to later
maybe because there's an interesting
sort of see you later this just looks
like you know [ __ ] Nazareth man
somewhere yeah but this so right there
next to the wolf that's Durotan that's
probably the co protagonist you the good
orc the peaceful guy and then next to
him is orgrim Doomhammer and this organ
do member which are gamar is named after
yes because he gone now you tell me well
can we no don't know is that considered
a spoiler ok who knows that's just not
boughten good this is Westfall though
which is also cool cuz there's a
harvester pointed out straight earlier
just hanging out and you know I think it
was all just like windmill farm you
stuff it stood where you quest when your
level yeah right after you you've killed
your first what
dude's name again oh that's stupid ass
hob hugger-mugger yes well right after
you kill hugger yeah just in the end
they'll in Farsi happen hop over in the
west wall and here they all are so the
deadmines is probably somewhere over
here maybe um and then all right yeah
what's going on here baby thrall we can
say that right that's sure all the main
character of Warcraft why is he green or
why isn't he green why are our parents
not great yes his parents are supposed
to be green hmm because the frost wolves
apparently lived near fell magic so
they're all supposed to be tainted by
that so that transitive brown skin green
but I'm guessing that his parents aren't
green because it would probably confuse
the audience right I can think oh green
you're supposed to be the battle works
yeah the good works which are brown ya
boy rich which one of yous the shrek
like that's gone I don't know what the
point of reference is gonna be with this
but yeah you're right it's gonna be
interesting to see how how that all gets
resolved I guess there's Durotan and his
wife mmm chang'an air it's a Thrall yeah
there's his emotional eyes deeply
conflicted got out my he's got some
rings and some like at this whole
situation looks great body modification
he really is teeth orcs are just killing
it okay here we are we're back in
stormwind probably yeah he's got a sweet
hot he's freaking out that's definitely
wins it looks beautiful looks great
super white looks way bigger than it
doesn't the game just just to say also
Westfall would just be our ice well
there that's it there that stuns it oh
yeah yeah we're on the right nice i cute
so da squad is actually looking not too
bad yeah if this was like world of
warcraft there's the river and does go
to be brown as all brown and black yeah
and that means stranglethorn vale is
just behind here then i guess yeah oh
that's cool that they did all right very
good very good geographical knowledge on
this list geographical the [ __ ] yeah
yeah very good useless only a line store
don't ask me anything about the hordes
though am so this situation here is this
outside they've definitely set up caps
and we're so this is the interesting one
right because well the dark portals in
the background there on the right oh yes
so that would mean this is the badly
but the dis covered in grass so do you
think that other green explosion was
this getting stripped maybe and that's
why the because the Badlands in World of
Warcraft is like this deserted think it
looks like you know Arizona basically
and it looks okay to me you know usually
when you're in the Badlands you're
fighting all these like molten rocks
with like green glow and stuff that's
brilliant stuff right yeah so I think
Burning Legion at some point invaded the
Badlands and that probably destroyed all
the greenery maybe yeah that makes sense
right it's good this cover yeah it's
it's it's good I just yeah I found that
maybe someone else knows in the comments
can tell us but yeah I found out like
interesting that is all this like
vegetation there which yeah they're not
so this is definitely bad land self
because that's where the Dark Portal is
oh there's a Doomhammer yeah yeah just
hang a nap I loved you I love he looks
great i love them in the shield and
what's going on here burning is this or
Connor work action / final work those
are bad works because they're green yeah
they're not happy someone got shot in
the face this know this area I don't
know what this is it's doing my head in
i thought it was thousand needles or
something for a second but oh like cuz
thousand ezel does eventually get
flooded but that doesn't happen to
cataclysm yeah but yeah that's a good
point and i don't know if they had any
encampments there anyways the humans
right yeah needles at least not that we
saw some flights getting destroyed and
it's also on the wrong Island and it's
far away from everything outside or so
completely irrelevant so unless this is
the other side of the dam maybe but
again that doesn't get destroyed until
no I guess it's closed yesterday me
that's just I feel like if I had been
there during wow I would have remembered
falling off of that thank you Paul is
great and then they ruined it in
Cataclysm so I'm wondering if M this is
probably the other side of the dime when
we saw that when we saw that I'm battle
happening back here maybe that's part of
that this whole thing this area maybe I
don't know but then it's awesome looking
here at there so oh yes II this is red
Ridge because yeah you cross this bridge
and then there's quests oh yeah you're
right Jay I remember that yeah okay see
that's that's our guest at least I know
someone's gonna get mad we've got so
much more than straight again through
let's keep going
so we were at this situation very nice
cg row okay we can talk about the
quality of the CG in a little bit but
here we have hey what's going on here
what should I can have a disk geiger
Mona hanging out with Lothar yeah so
corona is half orc and half human yeah
isn't that her surname half orkin yeah
huh forcing a foursome a bargain yes not
very subtle which later they changed her
to be half something else instead of
human but that don't really no one needs
to know that so they're gonna pile up
for presumably against other orcs yes so
they're meeting up here and corona
probably would be the mediator I guess
she's obviously half this summer we are
once again as the pelvic cydia dollar on
yes every time you take Kate Griffin
they're rushing through what looks like
the Elwynn forest or that could be dusk
what actually maybe it looks a bit
darker maybe that's probably yeah yeah
you know since this is so far back
there's probably no distinguishing
elements to these you're right actually
yeah everything's green yes stitches
properties in walking around yes and
this kind of looks like that whole area
as well there's do there's a guy
throwing a horse or great tactic Phil
buff here we have some snow situations
so again that could be a threat that's
rock we saw or probably I wonder if
we'll see dwarves they just invaded Don
Mora and they're like EDSA aren't
iron-forged me like what the hell are
you guys doing here and got some so
there we go see that's important right
so that's Durotan fighting huh let's go
down actually oh really yes cuz he see
how yes spikes on his back and he has
skulls on little spice tree that's it
who is he for so go dan isn't orc and
he's a warlock that gets manipulated by
the burning legion and who are the
burning legion right you probably won't
find out in this movie but let's just
say it's gonna be teaching see how much
they dive into all of this stuff because
there's so much to so many people who
the burning like getting people to
understand to two different orcs are is
gonna be difficult enough as it is yeah
like which ones which I need to know is
that's probably going to be the main
antagonist in this movie and
alright enemies will unite yeah it's a
movie they're hanging out she's they're
just friends i think in the game so
don't think that's anything romantic you
need to have its a hollywood movie man
you need to kind of adjust its just oh
interspecies well right yeah 2015 and
this looks like some kind of suspects EG
especially this little child over here
oh right photoshopped a little bit yeah
stormwind as well I want I've gone I'm
pretty sure that's just the main
entrance to the palace right yeah you
just go in seems like it I don't know
what they're celebrating they're gonna
have not terribly obvious everyone's
happy cuz that have been storm when just
rallying I go I actually can you rewind
to they're like yo when are you guys
gonna look at this guy over here with
this his robes is that an elf maybe or
is that you think I happens cuz I hasn't
been Oh many casters apparently
obviously with all the majors obviously
they will be casters but like yeah
you're right like but I down over here
also you're like hi else right oh yeah
you're right notice this when we're
going through it look is a dwarf there
you think that yeah this is this is it's
not part of lord of rings when they all
go I bet this is the final scene I bet
this the last single movie yeah he just
did it all out of all the other border
they definitely have to have high elves
in this movie though right because
they're going to dollar on so yeah
there's gonna be also sure all these
people here I've actually gathered to
ask for an auction house that's what it
is Yeah Yeah right I am alright you got
scared lady with her baby at captured by
orcs presumably more more read on works
mrs. uncle green orc action here we have
Moses aww bye-bye throne Jesus he's not
very happy she's like why did you do
this but it doesn't matter because our
son will save all the people from the
Egyptians years from now no one
understands that except for people that
have played at least two or three
expansions right yeah um there's a two
boys again find alongside each other I
get a lot of this stuff looks like it's
jumping back and forth between oh yeah
that's hilarious times the game here's a
big fight basically brown orcs and
humans vs green green arcs yet
a lot of screaming my favorite part is
where the [ __ ] are his shoes oh just no
shoes why this is can you imagine how
much cooler it would have been in
vanilla wow this is how you got a
Griffin haha you just jumped off
something you gotta take your shoes off
turn off boom you're gonna hurt your
Griffin look at this situation this
looks like it's probably so so in the
background there that's the Dark Portal
right yes you see that's how I'm sorry
it looks like it's the same area though
right you know cuz it that looks like
the Dark Portal but it looks like here
yeah buildings I don't know it's
definitely ought to be a dark yeah it is
look at there it is yeah there it is
definitely not for so big battles gonna
happen at the dock for at the end
probably and there you go it's called
Warcraft and it really looks like the
first of what they hope is a bunch of
movies oh it's definitely gonna be a
bunch of movies as well June 2016 and
that was our very very complicated very
much okay yeah only while players will
understand analysis they are doing a
really tough job because they're trying
to create a game which is going to
appeal to people who love Warcraft
people who like warcraft and but like
don't have deep knowledge like us yeah
had people who just want to see an
action movie it's kind of difficult they
got to make everyone happy hmm so
they're gonna break a few elements here
and there probably yeah neurodevelopment
sins you know probably skew things here
and there but yeah yeah looks
interesting and last point on other
guesses what do you think about the CG
because some of us especially when you
watch like wow cinematics mm-hmm you
kind of like somebody's looks a little
bit flaky does it look flaky though I
know that people have been saying that I
don't know to me it looks pretty good
yeah I mean it's a little corny looking
but that's how Blizzard stuff is yay the
story is a little corny it's a little
stereotypical with somebody kick am
murloc I hope so let's just at the end
just throw it in oh yeah they gotta do
that right oh yeah all right well I
guess we'll find out more in June 2016
but until then for all of your hot video
game and entertainment at gamespot com
you